hammer der woche im
nordrhein-westfälischen bad neustadt hat
die stadt die wiedenest straße komplett
saniert frischer asphalt deckel neue
kanalisation fahrradschutzstreifen und
schicke neue gehwege
eigentlich müssten die anwohner dafür
750.000 euro zahlen
aber die verwaltung hat die fristen
verpennt und die bescheide nicht
verschickt zahlen müssen für den
städtischen fehler jetzt alle
bergneustädter ich habe eigentlich
gedacht wie ich da die liebsten hätte
das wie ein aprilscherz gewesen wenn der
erste april gewesen wäre also für mich
ist überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen und
fassbar
ich finde es einfach nur unverschämt
dass es einfach so die 750.000 säure von
den steuerzahlern halt genommen wird und
dann einfach futsch sind die andere
kommunen wo man sicher auch kennt sie
lachend förmlich aus ihr könnt ihr
kriegt doch nichts auf der reise nach
dem motto tut mir weh weil sie ethische
2013 beginnen die arbeiten in der
maroden die weststraße sie muss komplett
saniert werden mit allen
versorgungsleitungen dafür müssen die
anwohner mehrere hunderttausend euro
voraus zahlen
ende dezember 2014 wird die straße
abgenommen und eröffnet ab diesem
zeitpunkt hat die stadt vier jahre für
die schlussrechnung aber im
bergneustädter rathaus passiert nichts
der zuständige sachbearbeiter ist jahre
lang krank und auch sonst kümmert sich
niemand so geht der hoch verschuldeten
kommune einer dreiviertel million euro
flöten selbst die anwohner die von dem
riesen fehler profitieren haben
gemischte gefühle
als anlieger freut man sich aber es darf
nicht passieren denn es bleibt
letztendlich an jedem eck neustädter
bürger hängen im bergneustädter rathaus
versucht bürgermeister wilfried holberg
die blamage erst gar nicht schönzureden
der ärger der menschen ist für mich
vollkommen verständlich ich kann das
vorkommen mittragen dass hier das
gleichberechtigungs das
gleichbehandlungsprinzip stark leitet
und stark in anspruch genommen wird
es ist bleibt trotzdem ein nicht wieder
gut zu machender fehler das muss ich so
eingestehen vielen bergneustädter
bürgern geht die wortreiche
entschuldigung des bürgermeisters nicht
weit genug
ich würde das so sagen hat der
bürgermeister und die angestellte selber
bezahlen müssen dass ihr versäumnis der
rest bleibt jetzt bei der allgemeinheit
hängen ist für verloren das geld
zumindest die anwohner der wiesenstraße
können sich bald die hände reiben denn
mitte september ist zahltag dann müssen
sogar ihre vorauszahlungen in höhe von
mehr als eine halbe million euro
zurückerstattet werden